this is a production of cornell
university
everyone's really happy to be here um
i'm going to give you a pretty quick
presentation about nuts that you can
grow in the northeast
and in general there are about 28
species of edible nuts in the northeast
and all of them are edible or at least
have edible parts some require more
processing than others
but that's just to say that there's a
huge diversity of food that falls to the
ground every fall
and yeah they're all
all enjoyable
but today for this purposes of this
presentation i'm going to focus on two
in particular
chestnuts and hazelnuts i focus on these
because these are the most um
commercially applicable
although you can grow all the other ones
if you're interested in wildlife or
habitat restoration or if you're just
feeling kind of nutty
so don't let my focus on these two
dissuade you from your other interests
starting off with chestnuts
the most important thing about growing
chestnuts is that you're going to want
to choose
a chestnut plant material that is known
to be resistant to the chestnut blight
chestnut blade i'll talk about a little
bit later is the most serious pathogen
threat to chestnuts and so when you're
looking at
um
procuring chestnut plate material you
want to look for chinese chestnuts
chestnuts that's castaneda mulissima or
japanese chestnuts castamia cranata also
their hybrids
um as well as either of those hybrids
along with
the european chestnut a casino sativa
um
chestnuts love really well-drained soils
it's very important to keep
their roots not waterlogged and they
prefer acidic soils about 5.5 to 6 and a
half for ph
in addition to good water drainage they
really also prefer really good frost
drainage while they can tolerate
temperatures of up to negative 20
degrees fahrenheit just want to
be careful with them and so planting
them on slopes achieves both of these
goals in one
they're also very drought tolerant after
establishment
and very well suited to micro irrigation
when getting chestnuts you can either
use seedlings or you can use clonal
material i'll go over a little bit the
pros and cons of both ceilings are
extremely affordable they can be free if
you gather your own seeds or they can
cost about five dollars a plant for
first year
they're very fast to establish and one
of the benefits is they get tremendous
genetic diversity as you would with
all kinds of seedlings
this all
however also may have some
some downsides in terms of
very variable yield and also
survivability not all of those ceilings
are going to be equally
resistant to the chestnut blight
and if you are planning on planting an
orchard
um based off of ceiling chestnuts just
be prepared for generations and
generations of thinning you want to make
sure that you're just continuously
culling
um for the best uh the best and the
brightest of your chestnuts
you can definitely reach commercial
potential again with intensive selection
and i've been to commercial chestnut
farms uh there's one picture here that
are based entirely off of seedling
chinese chestnuts
and the success here was just through
continuous culling over planting in the
beginning and then just very careful
observation and culling
of inferior plants
if you're interested in clonal material
uh these are good for if you want to
have yields sooner these can begin
flowering in year three
and you may even see commercial scale
production between years five and nine
um
however these definitely take more
establishment costs and just higher
plant costs and also more care
one
and if you look at
if you look at recommendations from
other universities a particular michigan
state university where there's a lot of
chess network being done they're going
to heavily
pressure you to get clonal material um
and that's that can be your choice but
it's not
in my experience it's not necessarily
necessary
one issue
with clonal plant material and chestnuts
is a lot of them are based off of grafts
and there's this phenomenon of
delayed graft failure which is a genetic
incompatibility between the scion and
the root stock it can be a bit
unpredictable
um and scientists are still studying it
to figure out which plants this happens
to which
like which cultivars which species this
happens to
um and so this can happen after you know
five to ten years after you've planted
these plants so it can be really
frustrating if you've invested serious
amounts of money
into uh clonal orchards
um
but however there are recent advances in
micropropagation for chestnuts that's
tissue culturing and so we may this may
be a huge game changer in terms of
clonal propagation of
of cultivars
so we will see what the future holds
when you actually go to plantings you're
going to be looking for a final spacing
between 30 feet to 50 feet per plant
depending on if you're using ceilings or
grafts seedlings tend to be a bit larger
than grafts are
and one thing that's uh
an advantage of chestnuts is that they
don't begin pollinating until mid-june
so this helps to us this helps to avoid
a lot of the late spring frost that we
have been seeing in in new york and the
northeast more generally
chestnuts are self-incompatible so you
will need to either plant completely
genetically diverse seedlings or if you
are using cultivars you'll need to
select multiple different cultivars
some cultivars are very well suited
towards
production others are very well suited
towards actually shedding pollen and so
you can mix and match and design your
orchard to use use both of those
strengths
at a
about 50 trees per acre which is an
approximate
final
plant planting density
at maturity for chestnuts you can expect
about 2 000 to 3 500 pounds of chestnuts
per acre
um and you'll see this diagram comes
from michigan state university where i
mentioned before they're doing lots of
research
and they recommend
excuse me um
mixing your production cultivars with
your pollenizing cultivars
they say here to pay attention to the
wind direction although recent research
has shown that chestnuts are not uh
expressly when pollinated they're also
applauded by beetles so you don't need
to worry too much about thinking about
wind direction but really the big
picture here is you want to intersperse
your production cultivars with your
pollenizing cultivars
the most important the most serious um
fungal pathogen or the most serious
disease in general for transplants is
the chestnut blight and it's very easy
to manage for this if you're choosing
the right plant material so if you're
going to be growing chestnuts and you
want to be absolutely certain you're not
going to
have your trees to come to blight you
will definitely want to choose
time tested and
verified plant material it's going to
come from asian chestnut species they
might be
completely chinese chestnuts or japanese
chestnuts they might be hybrids
of either of those asian species as well
as hybrids of those asian species with
the european
um species
and if you do find a blight on your farm
you will definitely want to call it it
will it can spread and make sure that
you're sanitizing your tools to alcohol
so you're not spreading it across your
farm
other serious diseases to think about
are phytophthora root rot and this is
very easily
managed by using the correct
cultivars as well as planting in a site
that has good water drainage
there's also a phenomenon called blossom
end rot
which is caused by bacteria it's um
usually shows up in post-harvest storage
and so you really manage it by
um it's still being studied exactly how
it can be managed otherwise
some cultivars are resistant to that
and then two serious insect pests one is
the asian chestnut gall wasp which has
recently been reported in new york state
it's also been reported in pennsylvania
and michigan
and what it is is a it's a wasp that um
that lays uh basically lays an egg
inside of the apical meristem causes
galls to form
and really severely impacts the yields
doesn't really damage the tree
this is controlled by using certain
cultivars there's also parasitic wasps
that can be used to help control the
offending wasp and then perhaps the
largest insect challenge are the
chestnut weevils
they lay their eggs inside developing
nuts in the early summer and then after
the net fall
in early october
the
larvae will develop and they'll actually
eat their way out of the nuts and then
burrow into the ground where they
overwinter and repeat the cycle so this
is an area of active
research trying to figure out biological
management um there's current currently
there are um seven is a pesticide
insecticide spray that is that is
certified for this um but we're trying
to figure out how we can work on this
for cultural management i mean organic
management
and after you harvest your chest sensors
um they'll need to be cleaned and
sanitized you'll want to size them
you might process them for quality
control so removing ones of blossom and
rot etc and then put them in cold
storage where you can either sell them
directly to consumers or then you can
also go through and process them for
other kinds of markets
and chestnuts can be used for a variety
of products um you can there's great for
agrotourism direct sales
as well as value-added products
regarding hazelnuts what you're looking
for if you want to grow hazelnuts
successfully northeast are hybrid
hazelnuts and these are hybrids between
coreless avalona which is the
turkish or european hazelnut which is
what the world hazelnut market is based
off of
as and it's a hybrid between that and
american species of hazelnuts so the
american species confer
cold hardiness and disease resistance to
the eastern filbert plate
and the
european chest hazelnuts confer
large nut sizes and thin shells
casements are really easy to grow
they're they're value widely adapted and
can be productive on very marginal land
including steep slopes and erosion-prone
land they tolerate clay and sandy soils
and can tolerate a wide range of phs
they do not want to be planted in water
saturated soils and if you plant them
your forests you will have to contend
with squirrels chipmunks and the like so
we definitely
recommend you avoid planting them near
forests
and to protect them with fencing
again you have an option here with
hazelnuts of either choosing ceilings or
clones
a seedlings can either be hybrids or you
can use um kind of like pure species if
you're interested in just in wildlife
but if you're looking for commercial
production definitely go with hybrids
they can be very affordable just like
with chestnuts and of course you're
gonna get all the same pros and cons
lots of diversity
um
and also you need that diversity for
pollenization because they're also
self-incompatible
with clones they're more expensive
there are um
and they can but they have and um
they're more expensive but and you need
to get multiple cultivars because as i
said before they are
self-incompatible
there's many different ways there's
several different ways of producing
clones and including layering as well as
right now there's been recent advances
in micropropagation which is hopefully
going to
make some of these idealized cultivars a
little bit more accessible
uh this and the single species clones
can be grown can be trained into a
single stem trees and this picture comes
from rutgers university where there's a
lot of really fantastic hazelnut
breeding happening
um
unfortunately these cultivars are not
quite cold hardy enough
for our zones they're really ideal ideal
for zone six or higher
you can plant hazelnuts in a variety of
different um arrangements they can be
grown as hedgerows and riparian buffers
and they can be unprotected especially
if you're using
um wild uh cordless americana seedlings
uh you could be you can play them very
densely these are not would not be for
commercial but more for wildlife and for
conservation you can also design them um
to hedge orchards for
hybrids so the hybrid tend to grow more
as a shrub
whereas some of these uh some of the the
cultivars that are
uh cordless abalone non-hybrids will be
grown more as a single stem
tree small tree
and so hazelnuts can be grown for farm
production as well as for you pick
and you'll want to space them
accordingly
very similar to
chestnuts you'll basically want to
surround your production orchard with
seedling
um
ceiling hazelnuts to ensure a
sufficient uh pollen
pong cloud
and hazelnuts are
wind pollinated so definitely want to
make sure that you're paying attention
to wind direction
eastern fibroblight is the is the uh
most serious fungal pathogen for
hazelnuts and american species of
hazelnuts have co-evolved with this
fungal pathogen and are largely
resistant or completely you know
completely resistant
carlos avalona is extremely susceptible
that's the european hazelnut to eastern
filbert blight and so that's why we grow
hybrids of them
um and so
you just want to make sure you're
choosing time-tested uh plant material
and to definitely cull infected plants
prune out branches
at the plant will will succumb
completely to the eastern flood
philadelphia within just a matter of
years
insepex insect pests are not a huge
issue for hazelnuts at the moment
probably right now the most serious one
are the japanese beetles which really
just defoliates the plants um
and very the common ways that are dealt
with them will work fine for hazelnuts
big bud mite is another um
insect pest that to look out for it's
not a major pest yet but
we have seen it in upstate new york
um we're still learning how to how to
manage it and the other ones are not uh
that are listed here not extremely
prevalent
your worst pests will be rodents and
birds
um and so ways of dealing with those are
to make sure that your uh have your your
plantings protected
for rodents uh you can use dogs traps as
well as making sure that they're far
away from from forests and for birds
using distress collars um
has worked very well
and you just want to make sure also
managing or like monitoring your
orchards in the winter to make sure that
there's not
mice and vole damage
i think to feed on the
stems
as far as harvesting goes right now if
you're using hybrid hazelnuts still
going to be growing as a shrub and and
sometime and they can be very tall so as
you can see here in this picture
hand harvesting can be very expensive on
broad acre plantings and so growers here
in the northeast are experimenting with
mechanical harvesting and processing
there's uh and a lot of this technology
is coming out of europe especially
turkey and and italy
uh we have vacuum harvesters sweeper
harvesters and folks in the northeast uh
the midwest are adapting aronia pickers
and blueberry harvesters
to manage and sorry to harvest
um uh hazelnut
shrubs so this is an area of active um
active research and engineering so
that's something that interests you that
that might be a fun project
it could be some a great research
project too
and after you harvest them you need to
dry the husks off of them
separate
the husks this is a homemade um
separator uh so it's something you can
definitely diy you can also purchase a
machine here this is purchased by
rutgers university
and then you also want to size the nuts
for the market that you're aiming for
and here are some other uh you can
there's hand hand powder crackers as
well as industrial scale crackers and
separators that will separate the
nutshells from the nut meats
excuse me sorry about that noise
um
after you harvest them dry them and
dehust them you can then you can either
shell them or leave them in shell and
sell them directly to consumers or for
industrial purposes
you can also
de-husk them and and actually crack up
the nuts and
and sell them either wholesale or
process them into confections as well as
other value-added products you can also
partially separate them
and
uh partial inclusion of the shells has
has been shown to be very helpful in
actually expelling the the oil
uh so you can also make some very high
quality culinary oil
like this also hazelnut spreads
and so those are some of the uses you
can use for for hazelnuts because it's
very high in in fat so we call them
butter bush
and that is my super quick overview of
nuts that you can grow in the northeast
to give an acknowledgement to all my
funding sources and as anya mentioned
earlier you can find me on the internet
at research is nuts is my handle across
various social media
platforms and please feel free to reach
out to me sfb42
cornell.edu
thank you so much
thank you so much samantha that was so
interesting and folks we have a couple
minutes for questions so uh please feel
free to type them into your chat
um because
yeah nuts wow
let's see casper saying this is a great
talk
laura's also saying this is a great talk
um
i'm wondering samantha what do you think
um
what's your recommendation for a good
value-added product from chestnuts or
hazelnuts that you enjoy
hazelnut oil is pretty divine
um it's extremely divine and i would say
that's probably one of my favorite and
it's something that we really don't are
not used accustomed to here in the
northeast
it can be used uh if in salads as well
as for cooking so it has a very wide
range of uses
um and also for i would say for
chestnuts chestnut flour is really
excellent it's a very simple
um
value-added product
in terms of the amount of processing it
requires but it's so versatile very
shelf stable it's a very it has a
sweetness to it so it's really great for
mixing into other flowers for making all
kinds of cookies or muffins
um
i think it's it's a very exciting
yeah
exciting value-added products those two
are probably my favorite
and both of those sound like they might
probably fetch a really big return from
the market i think i heard someone say
chestnut flowers sold for 30 a pound
does that sound right to you um
you know i'm not i don't know it could
be i'm i'm not up on my economics for
those by added products but i do i could
imagine especially if it were processed
organically it is gluten free so you can
access some of those some of those
markets
thank you
yeah yeah good to know and heather is
asking are there currently many hazelnut
produce producers in the finger lakes
region
there actually are and they're growing
there is a newly established nut-growing
cooperative called the new york new york
tree crops
alliance and right now there is probably
about 10 members
uh there might be more i'm not in the
co-op myself but they are actively
growing and
not only growing crops but growing their
membership
and they're mostly focused in central
new york but there are growers
interested out in western new york as
well as
long island and even as far east as
albany
so it's it's definitely
it's on the rise and um
and i think it's going to just keep
growing
it's wonderful lots of questions coming
in too let's see this looks like a
lifespan for hazelnuts and chestnuts
hazelnuts and chestnuts can live
hundreds
possibly thousands of years so there are
um there's definitely uh
chestnut orchards in italy that are 500
years old not older
and hazelnuts can
while it's really good to
um every 10 to 15 years to completely um
coppice the above ground plantings the
below ground root system can live on for
hundreds of years this is extremely wide
ranging plants
wide lip plants
someone's asking about blooming time for
hazelnuts
yes the hazelnuts are really fascinating
that they they are the like one of the
first plants to actually
pollinate they tend to start pollinating
around here in
late february to early march so this is
in deep deep winter or not deep winter
but it's pretty cold around here this
time of year
their flowers can handle extremely
extremely cold temperatures
until they actually start to elongate so
the catkins can handle down to like
negative 40 degrees fahrenheit but then
once they elongate to begin pollination
they become much more
cold sensitive
um
but they still met and that is that is
um
the the native american hazelnut does
that as well so and and that plant grows
as far north as zone three so
they are definitely well adapted
evolutionarily adapted to pollinate at
the weirdest time
lots of good wind though around that
time so that's good
um let's see another question is there a
link you can recommend to order
different nuts
i can i have a um
if you give me a second i can pull i
have an online resource that includes
lots of different nurseries
one of my favorite ones is z nutty's
ridge which is in mcgraw new york
i believe their website just z nutty.com
but i'm not confident enough to put that
into the chat
but i will look up that soon and put
that in thank you
and we have one last question for you um
which is what would you recommend for a
general riparian buffer slash wildlife
planting
i would recommend
seedlings of american hazelnuts unless
you like gather your own seeds and you
can gather seeds of
hybrid hazelnuts so those work just as
well too
if you're talking about
i would say yeah small hedgerow of
hazelnuts
would would do well for riparian buffer
and wildlife planting plant them about
three to five foot centers
you could plant them just by putting the
nuts right into the ground
or you can
so because nuts um have to
have the cold stratify so if you're
going to be planting them from seed you
need to make sure that they go through a
winter cycle
um and then one more question just came
in they have a small hedgerow of
hazelnuts going to be thinned for
scrolls are a major problem in my urban
environment
well it depends on what you want to do
with this hedgerow if you want to
collect nuts from them and you're
probably going to want to definitely
scare off those squirrels somehow that
might be pretty challenging especially
in an urban environment but i'm sure you
can i don't know if you have a dog or if
your neighbors have dogs that can maybe
be helpful
um
do they need to be thinned i don't know
if they need to be thinned really what i
would say that probably this biggest
issue in a small hedge in urban areas
getting efficient and sufficient
pollination because hazelnuts
you need genetic diversity if it would
be pollinated and they are wind
pollinated so you need to make sure
that the pond is getting from plant to
plant if it's small enough planting you
could hand pollinate them if you have
the time and inclination to do that
um so you may i would not suggest
fitting them because if anything you may
be reducing the number of flowers
available for pollination
thank you so much samantha at this point
we need to move on um
your talk was just so interesting and
thank you so much and if you have time
to stick around in the chat and answer
questions we'd love that and if you
could share that resource about ordering
seeds sure thank you so much and now
we'll introduce our next speaker who is
dr yago hale
um dr iago hale
is a professor at the college of
agriculture and life sciences at
university of new hampshire
he is a plant geneticist and a plant
breeder he's done some really
fascinating work with the genetic
diversity of wheats
and he also just happens to manage a
gigondo planting of hearty kiwis way up
in cold new hampshire
he has roughly 150 different types of
hearty kiwi there
and he's going to speak to us today
about hearty kiwis from the northeast
all right so
first of all thank you so much i really
appreciate this opportunity to cross
state lines
and talk about kiwis so
the the title i think that was on the
agenda was the commercial production of
kiwi fruit
and that's a very big topic so i just
want to be clear that i'm going to talk
about the commercial production of kiwi
berries so we'll narrow it down and
specifically the commercial production
kitty berries and the northeast
um
don't have a lot of time here so this is
going to be a very quick overview
overview
what i want to start off with first of
all i just love being part of sessions
of unusual fruits and berries with
unusual people i feel like at home here
but i know not everyone may be familiar
with kiwi berries i do want to talk a
little bit about what the crop is and
why
you might want to be as excited about as
i am in terms of a potential crop for
our region
and then i want to get into some
production
questions that i get frequently asked
for those who are toying with the idea
of maybe integrating them into your
production systems and
give you a very quick uh look at
breeding and research that i'm doing
here here at unh
so to start off just about what i'm
talking about i'm not talking about
these uh these kiwi fruits that you know
and love from the store the hairy egg
sized ones this is one species of
actinidia one species of kiwi fruit
but the actinidia genus
has great diversity within it there's
over 50 different kiwifruit species
within the actinidia genus and among
those there are a few that are what we
term cold hardy and and for intense
purposes here it means that they're well
adapted to our northern latitudes and
i'm going to talk about one of those
cold hardy species and that is
specifically actinidia arguta that's the
little guy you're seeing in the lower
left
actinida gouda so it is a it is a
species of kiwi fruit and you can see in
the cross section it looks like a kiwi
uh kiwiberry but it is smooth skinned it
has a tender smooth skin so you eat it
more like a grape there's no peeling
involved and you can see it's relative
size to the fuzzy kiwi fruit in the
stores
all kiwi fruit all activity species
originate in eastern asia so thinking
about china up through siberia the
korean peninsula and japan
but they kiwi berries were originally
brought here to the us and actually its
introduction to the us to the u.s was
specifically
in the northeast they were brought over
by
colonel william clark who went on to
found what became the university of
massachusetts there was a big botanical
fervor of all these asian plant species
in the late 1800s into the u.s so these
were introduced to new england about 150
years ago 1876 and quickly spread
through different universities and
arboreta uh and also quickly into the
nursery trade such that by 1893
it was a very common plant in gardens
here in the northeast
what happened though is that early on
this plant was classified as an
ornamental vine rather than as a berry
or fruit crop and you can see this this
is the mount desert nursery catalog from
1920 actinidia or gouda is shown on
shown shows up here as an ornamental
vine you can see here planting of it
using it as a hedgerow and this really
defined its uh probably first 50 60
years in the u.s it was used as a
landscaping plant throughout the estates
of the northeast um here's some shots of
it being used on pergolas and around
houses really beautiful
uh beautiful uses of it and landscape
architecture here's a house on mount
desert island taken almost 100 years ago
with the plant growing up and here's the
same house today with uh the vines still
there so we have some very old vines
here in the region
and of course um here's the geneva
experiment station and you see actinidia
gouda being used here as well
as an ornamental line
the reason we're very excited or i'm
very excited about the potential of this
crop is that first of all it's well
adapted to the new england climate if
you look at its center of diversity
where it comes from in china this red
line is sort of showing a northern
maximum in terms of latitude of the
adaptation and that same line on new
york is about here so you can see a
great deal of new york state
climatically is well adapted to growing
this uh particular species so there's a
cold hardiness aspect to it
um and in fact there's uh the
main planting thousands of acres of
kiwiberry is in uh
province here in china which is smack
dab climatically with uh new york state
the other thing he's very excited about
is just the quality attributes the
flavor of very high sugar levels easily
well over 20 bricks
i have varieties here they get up into
the 30s so something that winemakers can
also be
find very useful but it's not just sweet
it also has high levels of acidity has
titratable acidity levels on par with
grapefruit so you get this really nice
sweet tart balance that gives it a
complexity of flavor
and the nutritional profile is excellent
as well
the final
reason uh that this is
i think you should give this some
thought is that um ever since about the
1970s into the 1980s there have been
some pioneering growers here in the us
that have proven the economic viability
of this crop although we do not see it
at scale we have many instances of
growers that are showing
viable yields of anywhere between four
to eight tons per acre and a lot of this
has to do with the variety that you're
growing and how you're managing it and
um the growers i talk to
basically the the demand for the the
supply is nowhere near the demand so in
the very high end markets getting
upwards of ten dollars a pound and then
for any of the fruit that is not grade a
there's a whole bunch of other uh
secondary markets that these can go to
again to wine makers and we uh we pass
fruit along to breweries uh jam makers
uh fruit leather and that sort of thing
so there's a lot of different marketing
avenues for it
so um i think
so it's been here for about 150 years
but it hasn't really got uh risen to the
level of commercial uh viability or
really at scale and a lot of that i
think has to do with the idea during the
20th century that
small things in terms of agriculture
were not seen as good we wanted bigger
fruit
we looked at something as perishable as
being bad we wanted things that could be
part of the global economic system ship
around the world store for six months
and honestly things that were unfamiliar
uh were didn't do all that well in the
market of most of the 20th century but
we've had a real changing of the food
culture in the last couple decades such
that things that are high quality um if
it's small it doesn't really matter as
long as it tastes amazing and has other
attributes like nutritional attributes
perishable that's another way of
thinking about things as being local and
rather than thinking things in terms of
unfamiliarity uh we have novel new taste
so i think we have a lot more uh
adventurous customers so it's not that
the plant has changed or the species has
changed but i think the market has
changed a lot and it's really a golden
opportunity to really to to pursue
uh the development of kiwiberry and we
see this
uh frankly around the world these are
the last figures i could put my hands on
these are a couple years old at this
point
but what you can see right now this is
areas of acreage of commercial kiwiberry
production around the world you see in
the u.s
it's estimated a couple hundred acres
the vast majority is in the pacific
northwest
which is odd because climatically the
northeast is much more similar to where
these uh plants are from than the
pacific northwest and they actually do
much better here but look at these
numbers in china china was
very much behind the ball in terms of
commercial production and there are
thousands of new acres going into the
ground and we're seeing this in europe
as well so we're i think we're seeing a
very big uptick in commercial production
and uh it's good we have an opportunity
to be ahead of that curve here in this
region
i am still trying to put together all
the places i know of folks who are
growing to be very commercially um so
i'm starting to put dots on the map
this is something if folks are growing
commercially i would love for you to
reach out to me so i can start building
a more comprehensive map but of the dots
here
a lot of them are very small you can see
here
fairly unmanaged
plants on pergolas maybe one two three
five plants something very small all the
way up to
big commercial operations this is
kiwiberry organics in pennsylvania with
over 20 acres in the ground so it really
varies in terms of intensity and scale
so that's a very quick overview of the
of the species itself and what i'd like
to do now is if is just address some of
the common questions i get first one is
i want to grow berries what varieties
should i grow
this is a very long story this is what i
spent the first seven years of my
research on is trying to figure out the
genetics of this plant i work here in at
the new hampshire agricultural
experiment station this is a shot of my
research vineyard it has since grown by
another half of this
i have several thousand plants in the
ground but basically i tried to bring
all germplasm together into a commercial
production system following this raised
t-bar trellising system so you can see
the plants here
and i spent a lot of years observing
these plants in the field and also
looking at their genetics and part of
the problem was that since the
introduction of kiwi berry 150 years ago
there has not been great uh organization
in terms of variety nomenclature or
maintenance so it was a whole period of
private collections things going into
the usda different usda facilities
closing
there being fire sales out to private
citizens back to the repositories such
that by the time i started my research
here about 10 years ago
it was a complete mess
we had different uh plant introductions
in the usda system bearing the same name
we had the same name like belfast bay
but in some cases they were male some
cases they were female
and so a lot of funny things happened on
the way to the repositories there were
gender swaps descriptors descriptors
didn't match historical records and it
was just a morass of names
so i spent a lot of time trying to
figure that out um
trying to find where redundancies
happened here we see three different
blinds all called some form of opics
which actually happen to be the same
plant so it's great to identify that
in other cases here's three lines with
three different names jumbo chico and
michigan state but they were all the
same variety
so a lot of a lot of my work early on
was just trying to get a handle on on
what we have
boing that all down where we are now is
after many years of observation in the
field and uh really sorting out the
genetics i can now very confidently say
that there is one variety that i would
recommend to commercial growers here in
the region due to its field performance
its quality attributes its post-harvest
performance and that is something called
geneva 3. there are a couple others ana
nas was grown in pacific northwest
i would not recommend it to growers here
i think the quality is not quite there
but this is the one you will see mainly
in the market i think geneva 3 is the
one for us and we also have a bunch of
males
that can go with it and i've been
working the last couple years with
hartman's plant company in michigan
genetically fingerprinting its inventory
so that now i know that if you go to
hartman's and you request geneva 3 you
will get the same geneva 3 that i'm
talking about and that's not necessarily
the case if you go to other nurseries so
go to hartman's look for
unh verified
logos on those varieties and you'll be
planting what i'm talking about
next question is how many males do i
need in my vineyard and the thing to
this is based on the fact that all kiwi
fruit are functionally diocese what that
means is that a given vine these are
long-lived woody vines a given vine is
either going to be male or female
they're going to either have stamina
flowers with pollen or pistillite
flowers that are going to give you fruit
what this means is that you have to give
up some of the area in your vineyard to
pollenizing plants and for our region
and here at the experiment station
um
we are seeing that a ratio of one male
to eight female plants does a really
good job here for us
that's with the caveat well first of all
to say one reason for that this is a
picture underneath the kiwiberry canopy
and you can see the high density of male
flowers so a given male has
many thousands of flowers on it so
that's part of the one to eight
but the other thing we see here is we
have great pollinator activity at the
experiment station
in places where maybe you don't have as
robust pollinator populations you might
want to do more of a one to six uh ratio
or even think about buying in pollen and
and spraying it manually but we have not
had to do that here
by and large bumblebees are our main
workers in our in our vineyard and the
the canopies are just abuzz with these
things although we have all kinds of
native bee species up in the flowers
so here's a quick diagram of what that
one to eight ratio would look like
again if we're sort of looking down the
row here's our t-bar trellises this
diagram is looking down from above
um you can see this is a modulus the red
square is a male plant and it has eight
female plants essentially around it in
rows and so that modulus can be tiled
throughout the vineyard and maintain
that one to eight ratio that that is
good
another question i get is when will i
get fruit off of these things
if you prune well and if you irrigate
and if you do what's necessary you will
likely see fruit in the third year uh
when i started this i was often told
year five
um but our if you manage it intensively
we're even seeing flowers in the second
year the year after we establish there's
a quick rundown of what establishment is
going to look like in year one
you plant your
you plant your uh your clonally
propagated plant your variety and your
one is all about root establishment
in year two
you're going to capture a single leader
you're going to support it with a stake
of some kind to keep it nice and
straight making sure to prune off any
other unwanted growth and really
channeling growth into this trunk
and establishing these cordons that you
see here running along the center wire
by year three you start training and
capturing what we call laterals these
are these small growths going
perpendicularly off the of the cordons
the trunk and cordon uh are your
permanent architecture of the vine and
spacing is going to be different on
these depending on if it's male or
female
here's a here's a vine
showing you the permanent trunk
the permanent cordon and zooming in you
can see these laterals
going perpendicular to the vine and
using these kiwi clips to capture and
tie them down
year four and beyond the whole idea is
that these old laterals which gave you
fruit you're going to
end up pruning off and replacing with
new laterals that year so you get into
this annual replacement of laterals so
that you're set up the next year
for fruit and then that's the cycle that
you're in
pruning
is uh
you can't over prune these things these
are very vigorous fines here's a before
and after of pruning a male vine and you
might take 75-80 percent of the canopy
off
it's taken me a while to get the
confidence to prune these as heavily as
they needed need to be pruned
but just to say when you prune a
kiwiberry vine you really prune it you
really take it down
um how do you know when to harvest is
the last frequently asked question i get
unfortunately there's no real visual
indicator of when the fruit is ripe they
look green when they're not ripe and
they continue to look green maybe with
some blush when they ripen up the way
you know when to harvest your berries is
you start cutting them open and you
start looking for what's called black
seed stage as the berries reach
physiological maturity these white seeds
will start turning to black
and as you start opening up a
representative sample of berries and you
see that all the seeds are black
then you start monitoring on a regular
basis for sugar content or dry matter
content
once you get a sample of berries that
have an average of eight bricks or about
20 dry matter you can strip the whole
vineyard at that stage these berries
will still be rock hard they will be
terrible to eat but kiwi berries are
climacteric which means you can ripen
them off the vine and this is great for
us and particularly for small berries
because we can get these things out of
the field before they become susceptible
to damaged like to from spotted wing
drosophila or other stresses
once you harvest them you can hold them
in cold storage for up to six weeks and
when you're ready to eat them you would
pull them out and simply ripen them at
room temperature
um there is one variety hearty red that
does turn this nice red color and it's
actually red flesh as well
uh on the vine and so that's a good
visual indicator and i think there may
be some potential here for pick your own
operations because a consumer really
could just walk up pick it and eat it
right off the vine
and hartman has that as well
this is a very quick uh run through i
want to the main thing i want to point
you to is that we have an online
production guide uh
noreestkiwiberries.com that goes into
every detail of site selection
production harvesting post harvest that
i've just touched on briefly here
an overview of the species
our marketing analysis we've done a very
detailed production guide as well as an
enterprise analysis that will give you a
sense of the capital investment up front
and what can expect in terms of return
on investment so please please check out
that site if you haven't already
um
finally just to say i continue to i run
a breeding program here so we do try to
have annual grower field days and
pruning workshops covid has uh
made that difficult
but if you want to
uh be on our email list for when we hold
those just shoot me an email and i will
put that on
um i have
probably more like three thousand three
thousand five hundred different
potential varieties in the field right
now because i have large breeding
populations i do a lot of fruit
evaluation
uh every year
and i'm working on defining product
targets we have a lot of different
shapes to work with a lot of different
sizes to work with a lot of different
colors and so it's a really exciting
crop
to to work with
because of the diversity that we have
and um
i think i'll i think i'll stop it here
the big takeaways is
first and foremost if you're interested
in kiwi berries please check out uh our
online guide
for sourcing plants go to hartman's
plant company and look for our certified
lines because then you know what you're
going to get you're not going to
purchase a female and three years later
find out that it was actually a male by
accident which is a pretty common thing
in the nursery trade and any questions
or comments or if you want to sign up on
our uh our announcements for field days
to just shoot me an email
the big take-homes on production make
sure to irrigate these things while they
get established really guide the growth
these are intensively managed plants
they will grow all over the place but if
you're on top of it you can channel
growth and get to uh
get to yield much faster you can speed
it up by several years prune these
things like you mean it and get your
fruit out of the field as early as you
can um i think i'm about out of time
many many people i think in my work and
i thank you so much for uh holding onto
your seat through that whirlwind tour of
kiwiberries
thank you so much for that presentation
yaga that
was so interesting from start to finish
i can't believe they've been in the us
for 150 years already long time a long
time and they are everywhere they're in
everyone's backyards it's
incredible so we do have to move on
there is a fair number of questions in
the chat and would you be able to answer
those in the chat
uh sure i can start chipping away at
those and i would say too
folks please reach out to me by email if
you have other questions and definitely
check out the guide because a lot of the
information is there as well
thank you so much thank you for the
opportunity
um and now i will introduce our next
speaker
who is mike davis
mike davis is the farm manager at
cornell university agricultural
experiment station and he also runs a
farm with his wife which is called
harvest hill farm
at
the experimental station he runs up in
willsboro
um mike has studied juneberries which
he'll speak about today as well as
erroneous elderberries and honeyberries
um so his presentation will give a nice
overview about his observations growing
and starting uh managing a juneberry
planting
so mike if you're ready i'd love for you
to give your presentation
folks here we go
introduction to juneberries um
i put together uh a brief overview of
some of the characteristics of
juneberries and
and then some of the things that
uh people want to think about if they're
contemplating putting in a juneberry
planting similar to the pattern that we
just saw with kiwiberries but just to
orient folks to where i'm coming from as
anya mentioned i manage the cornell
research farm in woolsboro new york and
that's in the northeast corner of new
york state right in essex county
sort of the eastern edge of the north
country
if you look on the right hand part of
this slide it's the field sort of
snaking down to lake champlain
we're right along the broad lake
uh burlington vermont just to orient you
is across the lake and then the
green mountains of vermont are beyond
that
we started working with juneberries
in
2012 2013. we got some generous support
from the northern new york ag
development program
and i teamed up with michael burgess who
is a
botanist at suny plattsburgh
and he
has done a bunch of research with with
juneberry looking at the taxonomic
relationships between the different
species in this genus
and so we established some variety
trials looking at the commercially
available fruit producing varieties
and then in addition we started a
collection
of uh wild types that are native to
the northeast
and um
that might have promising fruit
producing capabilities
all right
common names for amelanki are amalekia
is the genus that that juneburys belong
to common names are shadbush or
serviceberry
serviceberry is probably the most
commonly used the horticultural versions
the saskatoon berry
is the term that the canadians tend to
use
whereas in the u.s we've taken to using
juneberry as the term for the
horticulturally produced fruit that's
created a certain amount of tension so
much so that
back in 2014 one observer suggested that
this berry is causing a superfood war
between america and canada
i think we dodged a bullet there we got
past that war but there is still the
dual out dual use of both saskatoon
berry and juneberry
all right some of the characteristics
there's a picture of michael burgess
with uh one of the plants that we were
sampling you can see it's a large shrub
out in the wild dripping with fruit some
of these just produce an amazing amount
of fruit
plant sizes in this genus range from
shrubs to small trees
they are widely distributed so they go
coast to coast and they grow actually up
to
8 000 feet elevation in the rockies
traditionally they were a favored food
of native americans and early european
settlers they were also important
medicinally for for native americans and
that was particularly true in the plains
regions of north america both the
canadian plains and the northern
us
where there weren't a lot of fruits
that were native and growing there
uh
they were an important juneberries or
saskatoon berries were an important
component of pemmican traditionally
they are actually a member of the rose
family the rose ac and they are a poem
fruit they look like a berry they eat
like a berry
they really do look just like a giant
blueberry but in fact they're
technically a palm fruit they're closely
related to apples and pears
and they're hardy down to minus 60
degrees fahrenheit
thankfully we haven't actually had to
test that here but that's that's been
reported elsewhere
um
i think of them as the first shrub to
flower in the spring
they come on just ahead of the
the wild black cherries in our region
anyway
uh the plants flower in early may in
willsboro and the fruit ripens in late
june to mid july
uh
june and that's that just somewhat
that's that's not entirely true here
we've only been able to harvest in early
to mid july june is a little bit
optimistic
but i'm sure further south that's
probably
when they're when they're fruiting
okay the antioxidant profile lands them
solidly in the super fruit category and
that is what has generated a lot of
interest sort of resurgent interest
in june berries they have high
antioxidants comparable to something in
like pomegranate or acai
they're also nutritionally dense so a
lot of minerals in there great source of
calcium and it's also high in vitamin c
and this nutritional component really
generated a lot of interest when we were
first starting this back in 2014
time magazine suggested that this under
the radar berry
could be on its way to hit the super
fruit jackpot
now i don't think we've necessarily hit
the jackpot yet but there's a lot of
potential there
common uses for juneberries fresh eating
is probably predominant many orchards or
berry operations that have included
juneberry plantings
have you pick operations and you pick
has worked really well once folks get
get used to the timing of it and that
they're there
uh they're also useful in baked goods
everything from pies to scones
people make sauces out of them juice is
a big component
i had somebody contact me at one point
wanting to purchase a tractor trailer
load of juneberries for juicing
and then there's wine cider and liquors
are also options
and trail mixes and snacks so there are
a number of uses
for juneberries
okay if you're thinking of putting in
a juneberry planting
in our trials we trialed about 12
different commercially available fruit
varieties and these six floated right to
the top
they have nice sized fruits that that
great flavor nice and sweet
and
and they worked worked really well in
this area now all of these varieties are
of the amalekia on the folio species
and they were not produced through
traditional breeding practices they were
really just
it was fruit exploring practices more
than anything else so people wandering
around in the prairie they're all really
native to the prairie area
found a plant that was producing great
tasting fruit and a lot of it they
brought it into a nursery situation
propagated it and then replanted it into
these commercial orchards and and that's
really where all of these these six
varieties that i call sort of the
all-star team
it came from
in terms of citing an orchard they
prefer like so many things a
well-drained sandy alone soil with at
least two to three percent organic
matter
they'll tolerate a broad range of
growing conditions so they'll grow
in in less ideal situations but they
really don't like wet feet so if you
have a low spot it's going to show up
with reduced productivity
and heavy wet clays can be iffy if
they're not
readily readily drained in terms of ph
they like
ph ideally between six and seven but
again they can tolerate higher and lower
ph is just six to seven is ideal
and you know we always encourage folks
to soil test and adjust those nutrient
levels
prior to planting so that the seedlings
are going to get off to a good start and
get established nicely
in terms of orchard layout
we always put our rows north south
these are some of our early plantings
here you can see we put them on black
plastic beds it's four foot wide black
plastic we've also used landscape fabric
in the past
fast as well and that's kind of nice
because it lasts a little bit longer and
gives you a little more flexibility
in each of these beds we have two rows
of drip tape to be able to provide
water to the the
seedlings as they're getting established
generally recommended three to five feet
spacing within the row we went with the
four foot spacing and 12 to 18 foot
spacing between rows depending on what
you need in the way of
equipment movement through through the
orchard and whether you're going to be
mechanically harvesting or not we went
with a 15 foot spacing from bed center
to bed center
all right we control as always is key
really important to
to eliminate perennial weeds prior to
planting
once you do that
you know you're a good ways towards
getting the nice establishment phase
some folks use shallow cultivation in
open ground
as you saw in the last slide we
went with uh black plastic mulch
once the plants are established three or
four years in you can use organic
mulches and some folks do that like wood
chips or straw
you do run the risk of letting rodents
set up shop however so that can be
something to keep track of and watch out
for and then there are herbicides that
are registered for use with june berries
okay infrastructure considerations uh
irrigation really important during the
establishment phase
um
deer love juneberry so if you have
protected area to put your planting
that's great depending on your deer
pressure it may be essential
and bird netting dealing with birds the
the cedar wax wings in particular love
juneberries and i don't think we could
we could run our trials without without
bird netting um it's uh we actually have
one section of our nursery that isn't
under the bird netting and the flocks of
cedar wax wings that just show up for
that when they're when it's fruiting is
amazing and they they clean that out in
about a day and then they go and they
perch on top of this netting and look
down at all of our trial fruit below
so bird netting is key
you can mechanically harvest these
the fruit ripening is asynchronous over
generally about a 10 to 14 day period
and the so it's a little bit tricky you
can see in this picture you have some
ripe fruit and some that isn't quite
right
but people tend to target that
two-thirds of the fruit ripe
zone for for harvesting and the fruit
like apples will continue to to ripen
after harvest
in terms of yields what people can
expect
anywhere from three to ten pounds for a
mature plant
um and it really just depends on the
fertility and the health of of the stand
if you want to translate that into
per acre yields it really depends on how
you you structure your your row spacing
um
and uh and within row planting
okay finally just uh some of the insect
pests to worry about um japanese beetles
out there are at the top of my list
we've had real problems with those we
have used
some entomopathogenic
nematodes that presumably will hopefully
be feeding on some of the japanese
beetle larvae in the soil
we also have problems with rose chafers
i've never had anybody else indicate
they had problems with it but we
certainly do we may be the the center of
the rose chaffer universe here
um
they come out around father's day every
year and
hang around for a couple of weeks and
cause problems
the rest of the list
are often suggested to be
potential problems we have actually
haven't had real issues with these yet
really worry about spotted wing
drosophila but so far so good
and
we'll keep an eye on that they keep
showing up earlier and earlier in the
season so
that could become a problem down the
road
diseases in in our orchards here
atomosporium leaf and berry spot
there's small incidents it's definitely
there i've seen it but there's not a lot
of it it hasn't been a big problem
as with saskatoon juniper rust we've had
some of that also
but not a significant amount haven't had
fire blight knock on wood
but we're keeping an eye out for that
so that's really just my quick overview
once i finally got the slide show up
happy to take questions i don't know if
we have time for that or not
but folks should feel free to contact me
if they want to visit about juneberries
or have other specific
questions thank you so much mike that
was so interesting
wow and i know folks are um
let's see are there questions in the
chat
not yet folks please write your
questions in the chat because we do have
to move on to our next speaker but thank
you so much mike that was just sure
interesting
all right
wonderful
all right and mike knuckles is together
with dwayne smith um dwayne smith will
be our next speaker
um so dwayne and his family run seaway
cold hardy grapes which is a nursery
that specializes in cold hardy
grapevines
but he also has many years of experience
growing edible honeysuckle which is also
known as the honeyberry
um he has found them to be a really
great addition to his farm
and he will tell us more about that
right now take it away dwayne
well thank you it's uh certainly a
pleasure to be here um thank you for
having me um
yeah we've been working with
honeyberries now for about 10 years
and we have
a lot of different selections of honey
berries i always put hasket too because
that's what our canadian counterparts
call them
and as you can see here this is uh my
family uh that's a bowl of some of the
berries we harvest an example of the
plant
um
but really
i'm going to hopefully really
generate some interest in this plant i i
really think it's it's a great plant for
new york
especially in in very cold extreme areas
like jefferson county represents so go
on to the next slide
okay
there we go
okay
what do honeyberries taste like um
to me uh everybody has kind of a little
different view on them but mostly they
they have a blueberry
like flavor um but there's at least i
find a hint of blackberry um
flavor to them they're they're delicious
um maybe some raspberry in there some
people have been treated into grapes as
well so they're a very complex flavor
one of their claims to fame is they
have seeds but they're
they dissolve during processing a lot of
the jams that we make
are wonderful
they're seedless essentially because the
seeds
disintegrate during processing
a lot of the earlier selections
were astringent and that's where i think
maybe they got off on the wrong foot
with them
but
we've found the university of
saskatchewan selections uh to be
excellent and um
i believe they're gonna be players big
players in in northern new york regions
especially where we needed uh
a tough plant
um there are lots of genetic variation
um in the flavor profiles the texture
the color and the berry shape especially
if you look at them like on our farm
they have lots of ovular forms some of
them are
kind of like a football shape we have
some they're almost like a heart shape
they're quite lovely
others look like a bullet and you'll see
some of those later okay the juices
jellies and wines are very deep burgundy
in fact um
they have used them to create natural
dyes and a lot of dairy products
especially people who have food
allergies
okay
uh
as i mentioned this is still a plant in
development um
they originally were grown in hokkaido
japan for hundreds of years russian
breeding programs in 1950s oregon state
and 90s
and this is key university of
saskatchewan breeding in in the 2000s um
these varieties
are incredible i mean they are huge if
you look to the right there that's an
aurora berry um
almost what is that one and a half
inches maybe a little longer there um
delicious and i mean that's like the
norm we they fill a bucket up pretty
quick although a lot of ours we have a
lot of varieties so a lot of our jams
are made from a variety of some smaller
ones like indigo gem which is also a
saskatchewan selection as well but very
good very palatable very enjoyable
um
and they're continuing to grow in
popularity um and there are new
varieties under development all the way
from arkansas there's a russian breeder
uh down there and alaska so
huge range here
okay
okay it's a member of the honeysuckle
family um i can tell you every wild bee
uh in the north country i think this is
one of the first species that they they
feed on because it it flowers in our
area late march early april
it is not invasive i mean i've been
working
with them for over 10 years i have i
have nothing but good things to say
about them they
they grow wonderfully they're shrub like
we have blueberries too i kind of
compare them in terms of the growth
structure similar to blueberries
the largest ones especially our chuck 17
are definitely six feet tall at maturity
very large some of the saskatchewan
selections i have they're a little
younger aren't as tall as that yet
they have twin flowers b pollinated
fruit ripens with the early strawberries
and a month before blueberries although
some of the later ones uh overlap a
little bit with some of the earlier
blueberries like patriot
they're high in nutrients and low in
calories
very easy to grow at least i we find
them on our farm to be very easy to grow
okay honey berries love the north
country um they are northern boreal
species hardy to zone two
negative 50 fahrenheit although i think
they could take even colder temps than
that
um
they're as i mentioned april um
they're they're in full bloom and um
they can tolerate frost i mean a freeze
i have not seen any damage to the fruit
at all
um
they tolerate a wide range of ph that's
very important for us in jefferson
county we don't have a lot of conditions
conducive to blueberries we have a lot
of high ph to our soils
university of saskatchewan the plants
thrive in clay with a ph of 7.8
7.9 i'm sorry
um
this is key two or more varieties for
cross pollination i believe more is
better
um
you know back to the pollinators um
that's huge
bees obviously are especially the native
bees are going to be pollinating this
crop tremendously
and i i believe they have enhanced our
farm by attracting a lot of early season
bee pollinators
i lost my cursor
space plants at three feet apart for a
hedge
five feet apart for individual plants
here you can see a planting uh some of
our plants they're about four and a half
feet
i i would definitely stress five feet
though
any future plantings on our sites are
going to be five feet apart you can see
some of the pvc piping we're getting
ready to put the bird netting up
okay
here um the pb site pvc pipes we use on
our farm very quick to install and we
have to uh install them quick because we
have lots of predators before the
berries are even wiping to try to steal
our berries and see that later but very
simple we just bend the
hoops over
on little stakes driven into the ground
and um
run the nuts over the top we use a three
inch layer of mulch wood chips bark
we have lots of amish in the area that
are wonderful resource to obtain that
material
please avoid cultivating within two feet
of the plants to prevent harming their
shallow roots and the the rows should at
least be eight to ten feet between rows
for mowing
uh harvest
though the bushes do give some berries
first few years they definitely pick up
pace third and fourth year
um
the skins um will ripen first and this
is something we we definitely learned
don't pick them
quick because even when they look blue
on the outside if you pick them and you
open them up and they're still green
inside they'll be bitter and very
astringent um
you need to let them hang for a while
and taste them uh when you start to see
red inside the brix levels are coming up
and
the
they're ready to be uh eaten at that
point but test them first
um they're
like i said they are
very attracted to birds
uh fruit from the russian varieties
all typically ripen at once we find a
lot of the japanese selections tend to
be more
erratic although um
some of them are beautiful like i said
they're um
very good fruit but the like i said the
russian varieties uh
are attractive from a commercial
standpoint they tend to ripen all at
once shake plants um
we'll see a harvester here in just a
minute uh that kind of shows this idea
of shaking the plant to harvest
the berries hold on the bushes for at
least two weeks um we actually went a
little further with that but some
varieties like check 17 they tend to
come off at once
so
you just got to kind of be aware of that
okay
so here's a very simple harvester we're
actually trying to get one of these now
for our farm
um you can see
it's
essentially a frame that has two shelves
that you can shake the plant they catch
into these little stainless steel
shelves and you can tip it into the
bins that are located in the front
and this guy um
is the number one predator of honey
berries in fact on our site they will
start stripping the berries
when they're green before they even
ripen uh the cedar wax wing is our
number one nemesis um i cannot believe
how much damage they can do on a crop
that's why as soon as our flowers drop
we immediately put our
netting up to prevent this
little wonderful bird from eating all of
our berries
um
anyways uh
see yeah powdery mildew can be an issue
although it's usually in a time of the
year when the berries have all been
harvested
but it is important to know especially
the universe the university of
saskatchewan selections appear to be
more resistant to
to a lot of the powdery mildews
spotted wing
drosophila have not been an issue on our
farm
um
i don't know if it's a cold or what but
or the time of the year but we
definitely have not seen any spotted
wing drosophila
there's some wonderful growing guides um
obviously hats off to the university of
saskatchewan with dr boris
he himself a cornell graduate wonderful
had the opportunity to see one of his
lectures up in niagara
a number of years ago ago pre-cv 19 era
and just a wealth of information and you
know just kind words for what they're
doing up there and for the opportunity
that they're giving in this case in
northern new yorker thank you
um and there's a link there moving right
along
and that's our head manager and picker
my wife denise um there's an example of
a clamshell with some
uh freshly harvested aurora
that
we had some folks from our local cornell
branch had a chance to sample them and
had i actually been at the conference i
had some wonderful
samples of jam i was hoping for all the
people on this um
at this expo to to taste but um
moving into the future i i hope i have
an opportunity to have some of you folks
uh taste some of the wonderful products
that come from
uh the honeyberries and uh thank you
appreciate your time
thank you so much dwayne that was
wonderful
and we have
one question from jim he's saying
he did some work with saskatchewan
cultivars a while back in the hudson
valley and he found that frost was a big
issue because early flowers would get
killed and he's wondering have there
been any improvements on that or
suggestions for managing for it
yeah i i guess to speak to that i mean i
i guess i'm only a
living testament of how they interact in
jefferson county
but i'm going to look at check 17 as an
example because that seems to be on our
farm one of the earliest
bloomers
you know for lack of a better word
what seems to happen the cold at least
on our site they they open and we've
even had nights where it freezes and the
blossoms are on skate
um
i mean we get and this is every year we
get incredible crop sets so i don't know
what's going on there i don't put any
cover i don't put anything
special on them i do put one thing on
them to protect rabbits from mowing them
down
uh we use a product that they use it's
like a bailing netting it's a cheap
plastic netting that i just put over
the top of the plants in the middle of
winter to stop you know
rodents in this case rabbits from from
mowing them down the stumps
but um
i haven't seen any damage on our flowers
at all
so i don't know what's going on on the
site are they
are they
opening up in february could i was just
i'd be curious to see you know what what
is actually going on on that site
oh yeah i'm just wondering if jim has
any more information about that maybe
yeah
yeah easier to unmute myself than to try
and type in the chat so it's been a
number of years laura and i did some
work on them together uh back when i was
part of the regional team and
okay it was uh it was an early march
flower um
i can't remember
all the varieties but i know a couple
were low growing um
uh the berry the flowers would be out in
you know early march maybe early mid
march
and then in hudson valley we get a lot
of up and downs we would get a uh
a warm spell they seem to come out and
then you know a few weeks later it would
just uh get a cold snap and we wouldn't
get any fruit off of them
interesting
you know i i
it sounds like they're they're maybe
de-acclimating
very quickly um
maybe in jefferson county they're
because of the intense cold here they're
staying
in in the zone they need to be i
i guess we need to they're boring
they're a boreal species maybe this i
know this sounds great maybe it's a
microclimate here in terms of cold
that
i mean they were brought in saskatchewan
at least a lot of the varieties that we
we feel are very promising and that is a
zone 2 environment you know
they say we're zone four but i've lived
here long enough to know i've seen
winters that are
well below negative 40 fahrenheit which
qualifies for abort for the boreal
species and um i've banged my head
against the wall enough for working with
blueberries and other crops that do have
damage um
because of the cold here you know so
um that's a great topic i would love to
you know after this
talk to you some more on that because
i'm interested too on on how they
interact in different environments as
well sure i mean it's been a while um
and i haven't kept up with it i mean
we we had some lauren i had a small
grant got to get to get it started
uh we had some at the hudson valley
research lab and then some growers
participated and
uh you know things uh things change over
time and we we move on to other projects
so i haven't kept up with it but yeah
definitely you're always interested to
uh
talk more about stuff
absolutely thank you
good point
and laura's adding in that it may have
also been a thing where the plants were
very young because as they've gotten
older uh they've been fruiting well for
the past couple years oh
good to know thank you
yeah
so it's a little bit past five and we've
had
so many wonderful presentations
um thank you so much duane for your time
thank you
thank you and thank you to all our
speakers and thank you to all the
audience for just asking so many
questions
i hope you all have a great evening um
but let's
say goodbye right now owen thank you so
much mike for helping give this it's
great to see you
right take care everyone thank you
everyone
bye take care
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu